[Musik]
in einer zeit als das vinyl noch
schallplatte hieß war es so dass viele
menschen diese von anfang bis ende
gehört haben das scheint vorbei und
vergessen
marc engenhart und duc thi bui haben
sich erinnert und vor zwei jahren ein
unternehmen ins leben gerufen dass sie
playtime nennen spielzeit ein gesamtes
werk manchmal gehen die alm 60 70
minuten nur zu hören ist heute eine
besondere erfahrung die wir wieder in
die kultur und unter die menschen
bringen wollen was eigentlich die die
ursprüngliche idee gewesen man immer
playtime in einem deutschen kino wie
hier im berliner babylon angekündigt
wird bezahlen die besucher fünf euro
dafür gemeinsam mit anderen menschen
eine schallplatte anzuhören
an diesem abend ist es das album blond
on blond von bob dylan bei den
diesjährigen kulturmarken awards wurde
play teilen sogar als trendmarke 2016
nominiert
die idee etwas bewusst und ohne
ablenkung zu genießen kommt an
das ist das worum es eigentlich geht
also die zeit und play zu drücken und
einfach zuzuhören und die musik ihren
eigenen tempo zu lassen ohne dass man
jetzt eingreifen möchte durchs kippen
oder vorspulen oder verführt wird von
anderen möglichkeiten anderen fonds die
nur einen klick entfernt sind und sich
einfach eine musik hinzugeben
von anfang bis ende ein komplettes album
anhören das braucht zeit und es verlangt
muss sie diese ruhe haben heute die
wenigsten menschen
wir sind heute kaum noch in der lage
eine aktivität über einen längeren
zeitraum auszuüben
man lebt fassen im zwei stunden rhythmus
alle zwei stunden muss ein neuer impuls
folgen ob jetzt der theaterabend der
kinoabend der besuch von freunden ist ob
das abendessen ist alles ist sozusagen
ein zwei stunden rhythmus getaktet und
dann brauchen etwas neues die zeit
sie scheint uns permanent wegzulaufen
das ist ein phänomen unserer moderne und
doch ist dieses gefühl gar nicht so neu
schon vor rund 2000 jahren haben sich
die viele suchen damit beschäftigt zum
beispiel der römer senica damals davon
ausgegangen dass trifft die gegenwart
sehr gut so dass ein drittel der zeit
genommen wird ein drittel unbemerkt
entwendet und ein drittel zerrinnt die
sehnsucht nach entschleunigung wächst
und die menschen lassen sich viel
einfallen um den stress zu entkommen
wellness oasen urlaub mit tieren in der
natur mitunter auch einmal ohne
mobilgeräte auch das wandern wird
populärer
die verlangsamung sie wird zum trend es
ist sicherlich noch ein nischen trend
aber ich glaube er wird immer
bedeutender weil die bevölkerung schon
merkt dass vieles eben zu schnelllebig
in unserer zeit geworden ist diese multi
options- gesellschaft die wir nun seit
einigen jahrzehnten haben und vielleicht
doch ein stück weit überfordert
zurück zum kino babylon in berlin etwa
70 minuten lang geht das album dazu
kommen die pausen beim wenden der
schallplatten keiner der besucher ist
vorzeitig gegangen
[Musik]
ich finde das super angenehmen album
kino anzuhören und ich finde es auch
sehr schön die richtige lautstärke dafür
zu haben
daheim sitzt man dann auch und lenkt
sich schon wieder ab mit irgendwas
anderem oder mit irgendeinem bildschirm
oder mit dem handy oder sonst was
wer musik hört und so kommt man einfach
nur zur musik haben es bestecke das
bringt ein musikverständnis zurück dass
wir unbedingt erhalten sollten
es ist sehr interessant die play down
sind 70 minuten pause und das ist glaube
ich egal wann diese pause stattfindet
die morgens mittags abends nachts
stattfindet es ist eine pause die
ambitionen der playtime erfinder sind
groß demnächst wollen sie ihr konzept
auch in anderen europäischen großstädten
vorstellen